mind your decisions i'm preshtalwalkar
triangle abc is an equilateral triangle
point p is in the interior such that ap
is equal to 7
bp is equal to 5 and cp is equal to 6.
what is the area of triangle abc
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
one way to solve this problem is by
thinking outside the triangle
we will rotate this triangle 60 degrees
clockwise
now let's examine what we've constructed
first go back to the equilateral
triangle
notice the sum of these two angles will
have a measure equal to 60 degrees
therefore when we rotate this triangle
it'll have the same measure as the blue
angle
therefore the sum of these two angles
will be equal to 60 degrees
now let's construct the following line
segment
notice we have an isosceles triangle
with a vertex angle equal to 60 degrees
the other two angles will be equal to
each other and the total sum of the
three angles must be equal to 180
degrees
therefore the two equal angles must be
equal to 60 degrees and we've
constructed an equilateral triangle
where each side length is equal to six
from here
let's consider the triangle with sides
of 5 6 and 7.
suppose the angle between the sides 5
and 6 is equal to theta
we can use alkashi's law of cosines to
get the following equation
from here we can solve for cosine of
theta
we'll simplify this expression
we can then solve for sine theta
and this simplifies to be two times the
square root of six over five
now suppose the equilateral triangle has
a side length equal to s
consider the triangle with sides of 5 6
and s
we can use alkashi's law of cosines to
get the following equation
the only thing we need to simplify here
is the cosine of the sum of two angles
we will use the cosine sum formula and
the values we have calculated for the
cosine of theta and the sine of theta
we substitute those in and we simplify
we can then substitute this in to the
original equation
we then get an expression for s squared
which we can simplify to get s squared
is equal to 55 plus 36 times the square
root of 2.
we can then calculate the area of the
equilateral triangle because it will be
equal to s squared multiplied by the
square root of 3 over 4.
therefore the area of the triangle is
equal to 55 times the square root of
three over four
plus nine times the square root of six
and that's our answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube
see you next episode of mind your
decisions where we solve the world's
problems one video at a time
[Music]
you